estamos en presentes este pueblo
fronterizo polaco que se ha convertido
en un cruce de caminos hacia donde
llegan todos esos ucranianos que
abandonan la guerra y es en este pueblo
a 20 kilómetros de la frontera donde
deciden hacia dónde dirigirse dónde cómo
continuar con su éxodo o bien asentarse
en otras ciudades de polonia o dirigirse
hacia otros países de la unión europea y
lo estamos viendo este es un éxodo
protagonizado por mujeres y niños sin
duda esta es la población más vulnerable
y eso ha llamado la atención de las
organizaciones humanitarias que han
puesto el foco sobre todo en esos niños
que están cruzando solos la frontera son
los menores no acompañados hoy unicef
nos ha dicho que en una semana en
contabilizado más de 500 aunque
probablemente sean muchos más y para
ello unicef está colocando carpas en los
puntos fronterizos con ucrania para
intentar vigilar e identificar a esos
niños que están entrando solos en
polonia para intentar ofrecerles
asistencia preguntarles si están con
otros familiares o con otros adultos y
si no es así se están cruzando solos
ponerlos
a la custodia de estas organizaciones
internacionales y después entregarlos a
las autoridades de polonia es un tema
que preocupa mucho y que además las
organizaciones dicen que los próximos
días lo iremos viendo más más niños
huyendo solos de la guerra porque o bien
los padres van a morir en el conflicto o
también en este proceso de la guerra
vemos como las familias se están
dividiendo y es por eso que en los
próximos días veremos muchos niños
abandonando solo es la guerra de ucrania